foreign
s and refusals to quit
can you in record today Richard Sharp
bowed to the inevitable
I have decided that it is right to
prioritize the interests of the BBC
I feel that this matter May well be a
distraction from the corporation's good
work were I to remain in post until the
end of my term even before the damning
report was published he jumped whilst
attempting to minimize his mistakes
while I did breach the governance code
for public appointments the breach does
not necessarily invalidate an
appointment indeed I've always
maintained the breach was inadvertent
the corporation's chairman leads the BBC
board which sets its strategic Direction
budget and appoints a director General
good morning Mr Johnson did Mr Sharp
help me with your loan at the root of
this Saga Boris Johnson's finances or
the lack of them and Mr Sharp's role
facilitating an 800 000 pound loan if
you're offer anything to Mr Sharp and
exchange for your loan support a fact he
didn't mention when applying to bbbc
Chairman an appointment Boris Johnson
supported among the key findings from
Adam hepp install KC were that Richard
Sharp failed to disclose potential
perceived conflicts of interest to the
panel which interviewed candidates and
advised ministers there is a risk of a
perception that Mr Sharp was recommended
for appointment because he assisted the
former prime minister in a private
Financial matter and all that he
influenced the former pm to recommend
him for the job and both these
non-disclosures cause a breach of the
governance code
visiting Glasgow Rishi sunak again faced
questions about the actions of his
former boss in government Boris Johnson
thank you everyone and his former boss
at Goldman Sachs Richard Sharp why don't
you sack him months ago this is about
doing things properly and professionally
and when concerns are raised it's right
that there is a proper process an
independent process should his
replacement be a non-political
appointment and are you sick and tired
of clearing up Boris Johnson's mess you
know what I'm doing is focus on
delivering for the British people good
morning to you just weeks after Gary
lineker sparked a different BBC crisis
by tweeting about politics today the
presenter waded into this round to argue
the BBC chairman should not be selected
by the government of the day all this
does revolve around the Judgment of a
former prime minister but also that of
the current top civil servant cabinet
secretary Simon case it is he who
Richard Sharp approached about financial
support for Boris Johnson this is the
same Simon K to allegedly explored
getting a private donor to pay for
refurbishments to the Downing Street
flat who recused himself from authoring
a partygate report because he'd attended
a drinks event here during the pandemic
and who may have been aware of
allegations concerning Dominic Robb and
Nadeem zahawi before they were appointed
to Rishi sunak's cabinet both have since
resigned
the search for Richard Sharp's successor
now begins but as the government appoint
the selection panel the job remains in
their gift Joe Pike Sky News